- Hi, we should be under America’s Team.
- Um...the Lions?
- What?! No, the Cowboys.
- Oh, yes. Welcome to the Pari-TEA Party!
- It's pretty bright. Can I get some protection?
- No.
- Now remember, you're not supposed to blow it.
- [Herbert, Ekeler:] OHHH!
- [CMC:] We're here because we lost three in a row.
You see, 'parity' means there's little difference
between the quality of these teams.
Do I have to do everything?
- Not my first tea party.
- There's been a mistake.
We're um... kind of a tier up from these lower class teams.
- Your finger sandwiches.
- Woo! Not the first finger I've eaten and it won't be the last.
- But there's nothing better than parity.
Just ask the NFC South.
- So then they got Ridder him
and went with me.
[Kamara, Heinicke, Mayfield chuckle]
- Why are you here? You only have two losses.
- Yes, but we’re the Jags.
And God's plan is for us to just be okay.
- What a treat to share all these Zac Snacks,
with y'all.
Yes, even you.
The disgusting
distraction from the Browns.
- Ahahaha!
- We tried the whole being elite thing, but it was just so hard.
To Parity!
- [Jerry:] Roger. We don't pay you $65 million a year
to be treated like this.
- I'm sorry, how much?
- Get them, mid-season replacements!
- DAKKY, run!
- Not really our strong suit this year, Mr. Jones!
- [Dak:] Wait, who are you guys?
- Oh thank god, the Bills.
- [Josh:] You can't fall short of expectations...
- if there aren’t any.
- Oh sweet baby muskrat!
Even the Bills are just okay!
[chanting:] PARITY. PARITY.
- Take Dakky, not me.
- Ah, is that Jesus Christ?!?!
- Close. It's Jalen Hurts.
Take my hand.
Oops!
- [Jerry:] Ahhh!
They really should ban that brotherly shove.
- Why, Eagles, Whyyyyyyyyyyy?!
- Alvin, you know what I'm talking about.
You’re no stranger to a tussle.
[chuckles]
- Oh, you're bad, Taylor.
Now, I'll tell you what's going on between Olave and Carr.
But I don't think you're ready for THAT tea.
- Ohhh, child/He's got some gumption, don't he/I'll pay his fine.
- Why the f--k are you all talking like that?